نحن الان في شوارع مدينه خرسون التي
اصابتها ما وصفها مدير مكتب الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه باكبر كارثه انسانيه من صنع
البشر بعد تفجير سد كخوفك نحن الان في هذه
الشوارع التي كنا نمر بها بالسيارات او
على الاقدام الان باتت مغموره بالمياه لا
نستطيع ان نتحرك فيها الا عبر هذه القوارب
التي تشاهدون عبرها هذه الصور الان
المباشره على شاشه الجزيره هذه المشاهد
الان هذه المناطق التي نمر بها هي شوارع
على الاقل عمق المياه هنا اكثر من متر
ونصف ونصف هذه المنطقه حيث نوجد الان
تشاهدون هذه المباني التي نمر عليها خلفي
ايضا مباشره تستمر عمليات الاجلاء للسكان
بهذه الزوارق كما تشاهدون هذه الزوارق هي
الوسيله الوحيده التي يستخدمها
وتستخدمها ايضا الشرطه الاوكرانيه والجيش
الاوكرانيه والقوات هناك لكي يحاولوا
الوصول الى السكان الذين ما زالوا عالقين
في عدد من المنازل عدد من المباني ايضا
السكنيه في هذه المنطقه نستطيع ان نشاهد
هنا على يمين الشاشه هذه هذا المبنى الذي
غامره
المياه غمرته المياه كما تشاهدون وقد وصلت
الى اعلى مدخل المنزل هذا مؤشر بسيط على
حجم الغرق الذي
ادى هذا الانفجار الى احداثه هنا في هذه
المدينه مدينه خرسون تشاهدون ايضا عمليات
الاجلاء المستمره في مدينه خرسون هذه
المدينه التي تشهد على اضرار كبيره للغايه
في مدينه خرسون نظرا لهذا الانفجار انفجار
السد
وحتى هذه اللحظه المعطيات الاوليه تشير
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من اجلاء
اكثر من 1500 شخص عبر هذه الوسائل البسيطه
كما تشاهدون هذه القوارب التي تتجول في
المياه في ظل ظروف شديده الخطوره نظرا لان
الغام التي كانت مزروعه على الضفتين باتت
تتحرك